normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government big
news ladies and gentlemen the new Grand
Theft Auto 6 trailer has dropped and
fans are concerned it will be woke so uh
for context we will oh actually I don't
even know if can I play this official uh
like I'm not concerned about the
copyright stuff I'm concerned about
there's like graphic stuff in here but
we'll play just a little bit you guys of
the uh uh GTA 6 trailer and then we'll
talk about the game getting
woke all right here we go let's
[Music]
see
Lu do you know why you're here bad luck
I
guess all right I'm just GNA I'm just
going to say it right away the game
literally starts off with two women of
color in prison do you know why you're
here bad luck I
[Music]
guess
that's basically it then it just shows
you a bunch of shots but there's
concerns about the game being woke we
have this from Sports K that asks the
question GTA 6 reveal is just around the
corner it came out just uh today
scheduled for uh December 5th well the
trailer came out today as one of the
most anticipated games in history pairs
where it's to release its first trailer
fans have many questions about how it
will turn out a major question is
whether or not the upcoming game will be
which refers to a heavy focus on
political correctness and social justice
commentary I'm going to go ahead and
pause and say yes it will
be yeah the fact that we're even raising
that question I feel like anything they
anytime they remake something they just
are like and you know what this needs
some gender query and just some more
LGBT like is this what anyone who plays
this game wants people have already
commented when they found out that the
main character is going to be a single
mom they were like oh boy well they
needed more representation of video
games they they've just been crying out
for it for years what I don't understand
is why these companies do this cuz they
know that's not their target audience
that's not what they're you know
viewership or usership wants and they're
going to face boycotts but they continue
to do it over and over again anyway like
what's the incentive I've never quite
understood like just purely from a
financial point of view you would think
huh my users hate when I do this and
they don't buy my game I'm going to stop
doing this maybe they think the game is
so good the franchise is so good it's
going to sell no matter what and they
want to indoctrinate and give another
perspective on life like have you ever
thought hey 15-year-old boy have you
ever thought what it was like to be a a
a ex-convict single
mother well you should I don't I don't
that's I don't know if that's the angle
I think it's more like some uh uh two
things happen Rockstar hires a 24
year-old 10 years ago and uh you know
they're they're working in the mail room
or something 10 years later they're in
marketing and they're in their mid-30s
and they say Okay so we're going to
finally be put it's it's been how long
like 10 some 10 longer than 10 years
right since GTA 5 came out they're like
we're going to be launching Grand Theft
Auto 6 finally the game is done how or
or I'm sorry actually we should go back
in time a few years they said we're
conceptualizing this game what should we
do and this person said well if you want
to get people our AG you've got to make
it you know social justice and the
character should be a woman it should be
a woman of color it should be
uh all centered around marginalized
peoples and they were like really
marketing guy comes in and says look
GTA5 sold 70% of games to men we got
teenagers we got gifts for kids but it's
almost entirely young males how do we
double our Market I I'll tell you this
take a look at makeup the smartest thing
the makeup industry did was pay tons of
money to dudes who put on makeup because
they're like listen women wear makeup
it's a guarantee but that means sales
are 90% to women we could double our
Market overnight if we convince dudes to
wear makeup so the big makeup companies
specifically are like find me prominent
personality men who wear makeup and
we're going to give them a lot of money
yeah all of a sudden now you have people
making makeup channels in their dudes
and they backed drag becoming trendy
because not only do our drag queens men
who put on makeup but they wear a lot of
makeup so you're buying a ton of
products then yep I feel like theal
women are often times more left leaning
obviously but also more permissive of of
inclusivity so I think you know you saw
with budlight such backlash because it
was a male-dominated market so I just
I'm curious to see you know in these
male um dominated Industries if they
continue to kind of push back against
this stuff more so than women did I feel
like and it's not my area of expertise
but with video games and comic books and
things that I think of as more
traditionally masculine
spaces even when there's a little bit of
backlash it's not enough to change the
company mind the company just does it
anyways it's like it doesn't respect the
people that are at its core it knows
ultimately they'll play the game because
they want to see it what's a female
space like if male spaces are you know
like football and video games and sports
and stuff like that what's a female
space like movies you could say you can
go either way just depends on the movie
Salon Spa type yeah I was going to say
Salon like beauty industry women are
much more socially based and so you know
I would think like traditionally for a
long time it was like volunteer
organizations were predominantly led by
women that's a little bit that's not as
true now because we don't really partake
in cultural community events um I think
in some ways like online it would be
like the lifestyle vlogger the mommy
vlogger the the fashion content it would
be things that are more about that
you're seeing a crossover of like women
like I see a lot of uh push for like
women's DIY projects women using power
tools because it's them fixing up their
house but that's ultimately them being a
in a domestic traditionally female space
mhm I don't know what the hell helps you
with your question but that's where I
see women I don't know if you see women
out and about people are saying the
Saints Row reboot was bad cyber Punk was
bad I don't know you know maybe I mean I
I there there's an element of politics
in in in all a lot of these games but I
wonder why they they just don't make it
so you can you know I don't know design
your own character like with balers gate
we talked about that balers Gate 3 comes
out and you can literally make your
character some kind of freakish
Abomination you can make it like a
orcish woman with a beard and just just
go wild with it yeah you know make some
kind of monster that's effectively true
in The Sims 2 games I know there's like
hundred of them now which I think of as
being very popular among women but
they're not as fantasy oriented they're
not as sort of sci-fi also they don't
tend to go on Quest they just sort of
live at home and have relationships and
then you decorate their house it's
essentially a virtual dollhous I think
that I think what they're thinking with
GTA is that so the big issue people are
pointing out is the main character is
female it's never been done before and
and I'm not you know I agree with some
of the some of the counter critique it's
it's just because they make a character
that's female that you play does not
inherently make the game woke or
whatever they might be thinking like
well yeah we've done nothing but dudes I
mean maybe we make a female character
but I'm just I you know if you guys have
played GTA right yep you've never played
GTA never play GTA you guys look at this
see we're not the target audience no
we're not why would I want to pick up a
game where I'm going to run around
opening fire onto random cars m lessly
beat people in the street steal things
and there's a whole lot of other really
awful things you can do in the game but
dude is a woman it's like okay in in
every game you're a guy and you can run
around and just beat random people and
shoot them and just do all this crazy
Shenanigans but now it's like you're a
woman doing it okay so here's the game
you're a woman you run around Miami you
run up to a random guy and swing at him
and then he punches you one time and
you're dead and you wake up in the
hospital so okay with are you like
trying to accomplish something is there
so there's there's a story line and then
there's missions and then GTA V is
heavily online yeah I feel like the way
you're describing it you would want the
strongest character right and it's it's
like this push that we're seeing you
know with women in combat roles or as
police officers so there's videos that
go viral I think there was one this week
of you know four or so police officers
unable to subdue one male so I would
think that you would want the man to be
your unless her story line is like she's
going to go beat up her booyfriend who's
the reason she's in prison anyway no no
look look look I I I have played every
GTA since the very the first one on PC
which was a top down View and like you
can barely see you're a little guy and
you're running around it's funny then
GTA 3 comes out and it's 3D and we're
all excited I have never played the
missions never the moment I get GTA I
turn it on and I immediately just walk
around steal a car crash into buildings
launch in the air explore the map and
just go totally Hog Wild mhm so I
propose someone mod the game assuming it
comes out for PC I think it is and they
make it they can call it realistic
Edition and you can play the same woman
and when you run up to a guy and swing
at him it doesn't hurt him and then he
hits you once you go down and you're and
it when you go down it goes wasted and
then when you wake up you're walking out
of the hospital and if you get arrested
you're walking out of the police station
same thing the woman swings at a guy
hits him nothing happens he punches one
time and then you go down well that
that'll be the game it'd be more
interesting it would be it would much
more realistic yeah cuz then you'd have
to figure out how to live in this weird
brutal society that you're in as a woman
and you're as your if you're a male
player don't commit crimes but that's
the thing like if you're a male player
you're maybe used to having these strong
guys who beat people up you don't go to
the hospitals often and if you had to
play as a female character like maybe it
makes it more challenging because you're
not as good at fighting or whatever it
would change the purpose of the game
like maybe you would spend more time
scaling buildings and doing something
else and then that's one of the reasons
that I think video games that are
targeted toward towards men and women
are slightly different they are drawn
towards different activities their
brains are rewarded by different
Behavior so it doesn't sound interesting
to me to walk around and beat up you
know ladies of the night in GTA but oh
it's crazier than that I mean the game
it's nuts but uh sir do you remember San
Andreas uh yes I do that was the one
where your guy could get fat right yeah
if I hope they do that at the fast food
place yeah that's right in San GTA San
Andreas you could go to the gym and
start working out and your guy would get
ripped or you go to the fast food place
and just keep eating burgers and he
would get fatter and fatter this is a
good life lesson these are great video
games okay but I got to tell you if they
do that in GTA6 it will be the best game
ever cuz I will take that lady and I
will slam Burgers until she is massive
and then have her just like Bounce
Around Miami then she could roll people
over maybe she would have more ways to
defend I don't I don't know if the game
would allow anything like that but just
like playing as having this morbidly
obese woman trying to get into cars and
just like yeah it be tank just so heavy
every hit is just a hay maker to
everybody she encounters man I can see
that that' be fun but she gets tired
really quickly oh yeah yeah that that
agility definitely it's not bad agility
per for sure yeah thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net